So when we're talking about Blueprints, UMG and AI, we're combining logic and components
to create some kind of outcome.
So the Blueprints is Unreal Engine's visual scripting language.
UMG is Unreal Motion Graphics, which you'll be creating a lot of UI from.
And the AI systems we'll discuss inside of Unreal Engine.
So Blueprint, Blueprints and Blueprinting.
Easy for me to say.
Class.
A Blueprint class basically is a C++ class.
So the visual scripting is just housing all of this C++ under the hood.
So it's a core concept of an object inside of Unreal and primarily used to combine scripts
and other components.
So a class is what you will be building a lot of your functionality out of.
An instance is a spawned object of a class that exists within the level.
So you may have created a class and added an instance of that class to the level.
These can be changed without changing their instances or the core class.
So you can edit on a per instance basis.
In the previous workshop example, when we created a material instance of the other material,
we could edit that color without changing the parent property there.
And that's what we talk about when we're referring to instance.
When you select a Blueprint in the Viewport, its data appears in the details menu.
So you can edit all of this functionality with inside the editor as well.
And it's a visual scripting tool.
So Blueprinting is the act of writing logic via Blueprint script.
It's visualized C++.
So again, when we're talking about C++ being under the hood, it's all C++.
It's just a nice visual representation of it.
And Blueprint can be baked during the packaging process to optimize it.
So some people prefer to do a lot of their projects inside of Blueprinting.
C++ is a faster language, just direct inside of Unreal.
But through using Blueprints, we can actually bake those Blueprints to get more efficiency
through the packaging process there.
A difference between the Blueprint class and the C++ class is C++ is faster.
Exactly like we were referring to before.
This can be up to 10 to 13 times faster.
So it's better to do functions in C++, a better online replication controls and processing
math loops.
It's the low level language of the engine.
So if you can put stuff into C++, definitely do that.
But Blueprints have their benefit, especially when working in teams and collaborating.
We can prototype very rapidly.
So even if you have programmers on the team, you may find that programmers are still using
Blueprints a lot of the time just for rapid prototyping.
It's a very visual script that a lot of the team members can get behind and understand
how to debug their own information.
And there's better connections with the subsystems and tools.
So as we were talking about in MetaSounds, for example, which is the audio system or
the Niagara system, we can interface with other tools and subsystems via Blueprints.
And it's also a component answer window.
So it's just very easy to edit.
But definitely worth diving into the documentation on Blueprints to learn more about Blueprints
and their pros and cons over using C++ classes.
When we talk about Unreal Motion Graphics, UMG, we're talking about HUDs, like any menus
that we want to display in the game, any user information that we want to present on the
screen.
UMG has a designer where you can drag and drop text boxes and images and you can animate
elements directly through UMG.
And it also has a graph, a Blueprint graph, which you can create Blueprint functionality
from to say, when I click this button on the menu, for example, create this kind of functionality.
So very powerful tool to kind of create a interface for your user or viewer.
And when we talk about AI, we have built-in tools for AIs to kind of query their environments
and understand how to navigate the space.
We have environmental queries, which is relatively powerful, not relatively powerful, it is a
powerful system for AI to understand their surroundings.
They understand when they're visible, when they're not visible, how far they are away
from the player, for example, if you're making a game.
We also have NavMesh, which you can see on the bottom image here, which will allow anywhere
in the green space for the AI to walk around and they'll just try and navigate around this
green space.
And also, as you can see, it becomes darker green the higher up you go, which creates
certain conditions for the AI to think, okay, I want to reach high ground, for example,
so they'll try and find the darker green areas.
We have behavior trees, which you can see in the top right here, and it is almost like
a state machine in the respect that you can create conditions for AI to walk around, but
it's not useful to think about it as a state machine.
Behavior trees are their own concept, which you can automatically create conditions from
in order for the AI to navigate the space in a way that you intend them to do.
In these behavior trees, you've got all the things you'd expect from a behavior tree,
such as blackboards and decorators and sequences and selectors, all these kind of tools built
directly inside of Unreal Engine.
We've got a perception system, so you can add a perception component to the AI, which
allows them to see and hear and create different perceivable events based on that component.
And we've also got mass AI, so if you're trying to create a lot of AI in a scene, there
are ways to do that in quite a straightforward way directly inside of Unreal Engine.
So it might be useful now to give you a better idea about Blueprint and how to create a basic
Blueprint so that we can understand the value and just how quickly you can get something
set up.
So in this instance, we're just going to create a basic Blueprint that we can place in the
level.
We're going to put a box around the Blueprint to say, when you overlap this box, just destroy
it.
And it's almost like creating a little pickup or something like this.
So let's jump into our editor.
We're going to find some empty space in the map, probably where the player starts running
from so we can be quite close by.
We're going to go to the content folder.
I'm going to right click and select New Folder.
And I'm going to call this Blueprints.
And we'll right click in the empty space, Blueprint Class, which is the blue icon.
And we'll be given a series of options.
In other tutorial videos, we'll go through each one in other courses, sorry.
And we'll go through each one.
But for now, just select Actor.
And again, thinking about naming conventions, we'll go for BP, which is Blueprint underscore,
let's call this a pickup.
So BP underscore pickup.
So if you file, save all, and then we'll dig into the actual functionality into the next
video.